[Música]
como primera ministra del Reino Unido lo
hizo 24 horas después de haber defendido
ante el parlamento que no era un tipo de
persona que renunciado tras se marcha
después de haber fracasado en su reforma
fiscal y como la Premier que menos ha
estado en el cargo En toda la historia
tenemos informe desde Londres
Entré en vivo Rally Marcial decretada
por el presidente de Rusia Vladimir
Putin sobre las cuatro regiones
ucranianas recientemente anexionadas
analizamos en esta emisión las
implicaciones de esta decisión Del
kremlin
los líderes de la Unión Europea se
reúnen en Bruselas buscando soluciones a
la crisis energética y acuerdos para
poner un tope a los precios del gas de
cara al invierno Francia llegó a un
acuerdo con España y Portugal para un
nuevo gasoducto marítimo sustituyendo al
polémico proyecto
desde Madrid
actualizamos las noticias aquí en la
pantalla de Francia 24 Gracias por
continuar con nosotros Yo soy Juan
pupiales la noticia del día Está en
Londres con el anuncio de división de
Alice stras como primera ministra del
Reino Unido tras quien asumió el cargo
apenas el pasado 6 de septiembre se
marcha después de haber fracasado con
una reforma fiscal y reconocer que ha
perdido el apoyo de su partido la
política conservadora había defendido
hace apenas 24 horas en el parlamento
que no era un tipo de persona que
renuncia sin embargo en solamente una
semana tuvo que despedir a suministro de
finanzas y Recibió la renuncia de la
secretaria de interior los carteras
clave de su gobierno las voces de
discrepancia dentro de su formación
venían en aumento con 40 legisladores
que ayer mismo se negaron a respaldar la
postura del Ejecutivo en una votación
sobre fracking en el hemiciclón entrará
en la historia como la Premier que menos
tiempo ha estado en el cargo en la
historia y con un país a puertas de la
recesión y con una inflación nunca vista
en 40 años
hablé con Su Majestad del Rey para
notificarle que dimito como líder del
partido conservador esta mañana Me
encontré con el presidente del comité
1922 decidimos que habrá una elección
que se completará durante la siguiente
semana eso asegurará a que nos
mantenemos en el camino de cumplir con
nuestros planes Fiscales de mantener la
estabilidad económica y la seguridad de
nuestro país seguiré como primera
ministra hasta que se haya elegido un
sucesor
para analizar esta noticia conectamos
con nuestra corresponsal en Londres
Luisa Pulido quien se encuentra las
afueras de Downey Street de la Sede del
gobierno Luisa Cuál es la magnitud de
esta renuncia en la política del Reino
Unido
es un clima de tremenda inestabilidad
política la que se vive a esta hora aquí
en el Reino Unido el nuevo o la nueva
primera ministra será el tercero de este
año y eso nos muestra la dimensión el
tamaño de la crisis política que afronta
el país pero en especial el partido
conservador que ha estado en el gobierno
12 años la renuncia de listas no fue una
sorpresa de hecho era lo que estaban
esperando hace varias semanas sus
propios compartidarios que le eligieron
Hace seis semanas tan solo seis semanas
llevan el cargo llevaban el cargo 44
días pero también lo que estaban
pidiendo los partidos de oposición que
hoy han demandado una vez más que haya
elecciones generales para que el público
tenga la posibilidad de elegir no
solamente entre los conservadores sino
en general en las elecciones del país y
es lo mismo que están demandando aquí en
las afueras de Down Street un pequeño
grupo de Mani
se debe repetir ese mismo proceso que
vimos para la elección detrás que
sabemos acerca de esta elección Luisa
será completamente diferente El poderoso
comité 1922 del partido conservador que
se encarga de fijar las reglas bajo las
cuales un Primer Ministro puede ser
removido de su cargo a determinado hace
pocos minutos que para que una
candidatura sea seria necesita el
respaldo de al menos 100 diputados en
este momento hay 357 diputados Stories
en la cámara de los comunes y es decir
que para que una candidatura tenga
serias posibilidades necesita el
respaldo de 100 candidatos eso es una
cantidad bien importante y lo que quiere
el partido es hacer este proceso lo más
rápido lo más Expedito Y si hay dos
candidatos o más entonces podría
convocar a las bases del partido unas
150,200 mil personas para que voten
online por el nuevo líder pero lo que
parece que sucederá es que en este caso
no habrá que llegar al punto en que las
bases del partido
llamadas y será una elección de los
propios diputados Torres brevemente
Luisa Quiénes suenan precisamente para
hacer esos candidatos
hasta el momento ninguno ha levantado la
mano y dice que quiere correr por esta
candidatura Pero se da como un hecho que
quienes compitieron con Julio entre
ellos
las llaves de down in Street también se
da como un hecho que se presentarán
Penny Morgan el propio Jeremy Hunt que
es el ministro de finanzas en este
momento fue la premierman que renunció
ayer como ministra del interior el
ministro de defensa benualas y también
que Mike que tenía muchísimas
aspiraciones y tiene genera mucha
expectativa por su futuro en el partido
conservador y ojo a esto el posible
regreso de Boris Johnson como Primer
Ministro a quien las encuestas le dan la
mayoría era el reporte de Luisa Pulido
desde Londres y con el anuncio de la
salida de la primera ministra británica
llegaron las opiniones de los
principales líderes occidentales además
de lamentar las situaciones esperan que
su reemplazo llegue pronto y decían
estabilidad política para el gobierno
británico que tendría como nos Luisa un
tercer premiere en menos de tres años
desde Rusia celebraron la salida detrás
aquí en calificaron de desgracia Juan
Pablo lucumí nos cuenta más
la crisis en
Street genera ondas de choque a nivel
global los líderes de los países más
cercanos fueron los primeros en
pronunciarse creo que lo importante como
vecino más cercano de Reino Unido es que
tenemos una relación económica
significativa y muchas otras relaciones
más la estabilidad es lo más importante
Nos gustaría ver que el sistema de Reino
Unido esté dentro de la capacidad para
estar en posesión de tener un sucesor lo
más rápido posible y que traiga
estabilidad a la situación tuve un buen
contacto con ella coincidimos en toda
serie de puntos de vista y Estoy ansioso
por ver con quién trabajaré será de
quinto creo los líderes de las
principales potencias occidentales
desean una sola cosa para Reino Unido
estabilidad
quiero decir que Francia como amigo del
pueblo británico espera la estabilidad
de Reino Unido y en el contexto de la
guerra y tensiones por la crisis
energética es importante Reino Unido
vuelva a emprender el camino de la
estabilidad política a nivel personal
siempre me entristece ver partir a un
colega
Estados Unidos y el Reino Unido son
fuertes aliados y amigos duraderos y ese
hecho nunca cambiará agradezco a la
primera ministra listros por su
colaboración en una variedad de temas
incluidas las exigencias de
responsabilidades a Rusia por su guerra
contra Ucrania continuaremos nuestra
estrecha cooperación con el gobierno del
Reino Unido mientras trabajamos juntos
para enfrentar los desafíos globales los
comentarios de burla su corta
administración llegaron desde Rusia el
premio Nobel de economía por la
destrucción más rápida del sistema
financiero nacional Debería ser otorgado
a Trust Reino Unido nunca ha conocido
una desgracia igual en un Primer
Ministro
duró 45 días en el cargo y renunció tan
solo un día después de decir que era una
luchadora y no una desertora
como les venimos contando este jueves
entre en vigor la ley Marcial que
anunció el presidente ruso Vladimir
Putin sobre las cuatro regiones
seleccionadas de Ucrania de gerson está
por ella doniz y logans que esto con una
serie de referendos realizados de manera
unilateral por parte de Moscú para
finalizar ese tema conectamos con Álvaro
zapatel análisis internacional y
profesor de Ay y University señor Zapata
Gracias por estar con nosotros Cuáles
son las implicaciones de esta ley
Marcial en estos territorios ocupados ya
ayer Putin afirmó y dio más poderes a
los gobernantes de estas zonas
correcto ahora bueno Muchas gracias por
la invitación pues efectivamente como tú
bien has dicho el 30 de septiembre el
gobierno Vladimir Putin anexó las zonas
o regiones de Luján
y saporiya con la digamos la condena
internacional justamente debido a esas
medidas y lo que ha anunciado el día de
hoy eh Putin es asumir la ley Marcial
que es finalmente dar o tomar posesión
de control militar de las zonas donde lo
propósito también de hacer una contra
ofensiva lo que viene siendo un
contraataque ucraniano con el objetivo
de recuperar Estas son las ya anexadas
ilegalmente por la comunidad
internacional de parte de Rusia
la situación es compleja lo que
evidenciamos es que vienen siendo ya 8 a
10 meses de guerra en los que
definitivamente Putin debió y su
gobierno seguramente estimar que esto
debía ser más bien un blitscript una
Guerra Relámpago y claramente al no
haber llevado esto a conclusión y el
gobierno ucraniano tomando ciertas
medidas de control ofensiva esto ha
llevado al gobierno ruso a tomar ciertas
medidas de excepción que claro si bien
el gobierno ucraniano en las viene
llevando desde febrero que se inició la
Guerra la ley Marcial ahora Rusia lo
está haciendo con el propósito de
generar cierta situación de emergencia y
porque no también evacuar a 60.000
ciudadanos de estas zonas de conflicto
para evitar mayores muertes o daños a su
población de parte también de lo que
viene siendo la contra ofensivo craneal
Sí precisamente bajo esa excusa de una
inminente ataque sobre gerson Rusia
estaba cuando a cientos de miles de
civiles pero Ucrania dice que estos son
deportaciones que sabemos de ese proceso
Bueno en realidad lo que estamos
identificando en este contexto es que
tenemos ambos lados diciendo una verdad
una verdad distinta verdad estamos una
situación de guerra en la que hay
propaganda de ambos lados lo que he
identificado la comunidad internacional
es que lo que estamos viendo Es una
población que está haciendo
Aparentemente de acuerdo a lo que
indican distintas Fuentes acosada
atormentada por el gobierno ruso que de
hecho es lo que ha conducido también es
un momento a votaciones de referéndum
que según indican las fuentes ucranianas
pero también algunas otras fuentes
internacionales corresponderían a
votaciones
fraguadas o digamos fraudulentas a
partir de la coerción O el acoso que las
fuerzas militares rusas estarían
llevando o conduciendo
a digamos
afectación de esta población en zona de
conflicto en otro tema La estrategia de
Rusia en este momento consiste en
golpear la estructura eléctrica de
Ucrania de cara al invierno ese es un
crimen de guerra
pues definitivamente estamos viendo una
situación crítica estamos viendo que ya
han habido 300 ataques a centrales
energéticas ucranianas por parte del
gobierno ruso Rusia claramente está
buscando asfixiar de gas digamos a
Europa quiere quitarle gas a Europa para
condicionarla seguramente en tanto hay
muchas sanciones y medidas que Europa y
por supuesto Ucrania vienen conduciendo
contra el gobierno Ruso y
definitivamente es una acción en
particular hablando del caso ucraniano
que busca al estilo de la del de los
asedios de Las Guerras más antiguas
asfixiar a votar por ucraniano y matarlo
en frío definitivamente es una acción
condenable y que a todas luces muestra
una una intención de llevar a final de a
concluir esta guerra a toda marcha o a
toda Costa Y eso es algo que no podemos
tolerar Muchísimas gracias por este
análisis aquí en la pantalla de France
24 avanzamos desde Bruselas el
presidente de Francia Manuel macrón
entregó unas declaraciones en la Cumbre
de los líderes de la Unión Europea en
las que el presidente
tiene como las preocupaciones
energéticas como principal tema es la
segunda reunión de los jefes de los 27
estados miembros en dos semanas el
debate sobre si Establecer un límite
para los precios del gas es uno de los
puntos más álgidos de la agenda con el
comienzo del invierno en apenas dos
meses en este contexto finalmente
Francia llegó a un acuerdo con Portugal
España para la creación de un nuevo
gasoducto marítimo desde Madrid nuestra
corresponsal Marina Colorado nos entregó
brevemente más detalles acerca de si el
proyecto energético
habrá conexión energética entre la
Península ibérica y Francia pero no será
a través de los pirineos como pretendían
inicialmente España y Portugal esta se
dará a través de una tubería submarina
que una de las ciudades costeras de
Barcelona en España y Marsella en
Francia una solución alcanzada en
Bruselas que parece agradar a los tres
países involucrados y que en tierra de
una vez por todas el midcat proyecto al
que Emmanuel macrón se oponía
rotundamente pese a la presión ejercida
incluso por el canciller Alemán o
lapsols el corredor de energía verde bar
Marc servirá en un futuro para el
transporte de hidrógeno verde pero a
corto plazo funcionará como gasoducto
que cubra las necesidades energéticas
del mercado europeo ha afectado por la
escasez de gas proveniente de Rusia el
presidente del gobierno de España Pedro
Sánchez recordó que su país es uno de
los integrantes de la Unión Europea con
el mayor número de plantas de
gasificadoras de gas licuado y como tal
puede ser material energética y dar
respuesta a la demanda del resto de
países del bloque los detalles sobre los
plazos de la obra sus costes y el
reparto de estos se Irán definiendo en
esta semanas y en una reunión de Manuel
macrón Antonio Costa y Pedro Sánchez el
9 de diciembre en la ciudad española de
alicante durante la Cumbre euromed que
reúne a los nueve países mediterráneos
de la Unión Europea Nos despedimos con
información deportiva porque dentro de
un mes se inaugura ya el mundial de
Qatar 2022 se trata de una cita que dará
inicio con el partido entre los
anfitriones entre Qatar y la selección
de Ecuador es el primer mundial en el
mundo árabe y el primero también en
emitir cero emisiones de carbono según
las autoridades locales sin embargo este
jueves omnistía internacional asegura
que las autoridades cataríes no han
avanzado con una reforma laboral
prometida y denuncia a quien siguen
siendo frecuentes los abusos sobre los
trabajadores del país
así terminamos esta emisión aquí en la
pantalla de France 24 pero ustedes
Siguen con nuestra señal también visiten
nuestro sitio web France 24.com
[Música]